ow that makes me tear up a little bit
that's great mandy was great
tell me do you enjoy existing
that was a clip from the upcoming
thriller to say the least chariot
starring shane west who is joining us
now shane good to see you good to see
you thanks for having me this movie is
dark it's it's it's pretty i guess
twisted um but it's very unique it's you
know
talking about reincarnation and going
into
in and the problem with that is it can
get very confusing you think i'm the
villain
but this isn't giving away too much you
find out a lot more that that it's
there's a lot of layers i've been
fortunate 2021 was a it was a
fantastic year for me at least for work
i got i was able to do a lot of little
projects that are all starting to come
out now which is exciting chariot is the
only one that i did that was really
clean cut and looked like
you know uh
kind of an agent
and uh smooth wearing a suit smooth
talker that kind of guy and now you've
got the scrapbook the rest yeah the rest
is going downhill from there any red
hair on you that we're going to see or
is that just john malkovich that's just
john which he just decided on the day
before we did those scenes he just
wanted to add these little touches he's
i mean obviously brilliant actor yeah uh
but all the little things he did in this
film i think this is really going to
stand out for him wow what was your
first reaction when you saw him come out
a with hair and then b with red hair um
i saw him uh in the the makeup truck uh
starting to fool around with all these
little things and he he just decided to
put i think something there's there's a
bow in his hair too with the red hair
and he just decided to do that he's you
know i'm a huge fan
and most of my scenes were with him but
he was very giving he was he was uh
he listened he was very understanding
and look you just stand out of the way
you let him do all the work i just
reacted basically
when you're in such
a darker space for a film like this and
you're working on these scenes what is
it like as soon as they call cut how do
you get out of character for that and
then just chill with john as buddies not
as scene actors can kind of take that
home and there's a lot of you know a lot
of horror stories about that and but
i've just never been that way i've
always learned it's you know
you you take it to set but you don't go
home with it yeah so it's just just kind
of learning how to to to click off it i
haven't played some crazy serial killer
or anything like that where i've had to
totally go too in depth but i feel like
you just kind of
you kind of know when to turn it on and
when to turn it off you mentioned 2021
was a great year for you career-wise a
lot of different projects one of them
being outsiders license and registration
how's it going then excuse me
i'm sorry sir
how about that license
i'm just a natural fan of the shop i'm a
natural fan of horror thriller suspense
action all that kind of stuff and
outsiders came about at the end of 2019
and
they came to me uh they had this idea of
me playing the sheriff in a small town
and i added more white to my beard and
added white to the hair and just very
kind of a
grizzled not the best guy in that movie
a little bit more uh you know he's
trying hard but he comes from a line of
really corrupt cops
and he's got to get to the bottom of
what's going on in this small town that
one was
real exciting for me because i got to
age myself up i got to do something a
little bit different what was it like
seeing yourself a little bit more aged
the first time
not as fun on social media you know when
you start posting those photos you're
like you know you get some interesting
responses back and like wow he's you
know i mean i am actually i'm 43 but
they're like wow it looks great for 63
or something like that and um you know
so it's
it's a little harsh in that sense but
that's what i like to do i like to try
and look a little bit different with the
projects that i get were your dms
blowing up with just a different demo
no it was just complete silence just
crickets
when i'm looking like that oh my
goodness you also star in that movie
alongside taryn manning who is the same
age as you and you guys have kind of had
similar trajectories in your careers
growing up were you guys friends all of
these years yes we actually have been
okay this was the first time we finally
worked together
and even though this is blowing it for
the for the viewers uh we didn't work
together there's one scene where she's
in the house and i'm looking around the
house and she's yelling at somebody and
i walk right by her well a lady that you
have shared a lot of screen time with is
of course mandy moore can you believe it
has been 20 years since that film i have
to remember no i can't um i think it
ages us all uh but uh i think it no it's
great it's i love that people uh that it
resonates and that people still talk
about it and uh um
i was gonna say look at this throwback
what are you wondering about
what i remember about this holding right
there
i don't know
what happened that day um that was
definitely we weren't shooting uh that
was a day off um clearly i'm wearing a
green day shirt for god's sake um but uh
that is from a real camera that's
something that i can remember too that
was not a cell phone camera
it was probably a disposable camera um
but no it was uh it i love that it
resonates still and you know she's a
sweetheart and that was one of the
coolest you know coolest moments of our
lives you know of growing up into the
trying to become you know an adult
in a very difficult industry and that's
a relationship that you have taken with
you throughout the rest of your career
it's very good you guys are still good
buddies in fact we actually have a
little surprise for you we caught up
with mandy recently
and she had this to say about you
shane knows that i adore him and i
appreciate him and i'm i will be forever
grateful that shane uh walked me through
the baby steps of how to be an actor how
to hit my mark
i mean i just i knew nothing thank god
for shane
oh my goodness wow
what is your reaction to hearing that oh
that makes me tear up a little bit
that's great um
yeah i mean
like i knew what i was doing i was i was
pretty young myself i mean
you know me and the rest of the guys and
girls in the on the
on the set were in our early 20s but we
were you know
over 21 so we could go to a bar we had
some experience at least in the acting
industry and things like that but this
was kind of her
besides i think
princess diaries i think this was like
her first you know
really big leading role and she changed
her hair color which was a huge thing
back then she was terrified to do that
and i was still learning what i was
doing too but yeah you know hitting a
mark making it look like you're not
looking down when you're hitting the
mark or you know you're just trying to
just trying to be real about that you
know they say fake it till you make it
you guys are both learning some of the
best things you can say in this industry
that's for sure yeah she said recently
too that she rewatched the movie and she
admitted to having a crush on you back
then now was that reciprocated did you
like her back oh yeah for sure i mean we
we you know what i just rewatched it
again too you did
well i got up to the i got up to uh we
did the play
and then you know they fall in love
and then after that i was like i've seen
that it was okay but it was fun to see
the beginning and just see how
ah man just you just start taking apart
your performance and you're like why did
i do that
mandy was great but no we definitely
there was a there was a
there was a healthy
natural crush and bond on that and we're
very protective of each other yeah yeah
it's hard to you don't always get that
i've been fortunate enough to work on a
lot of different projects and you know
you don't always get that bond or that
connection we could sit here and talk
about that all day long but i know you
are booked and busy my friend thank you
so much for taking time
[Music]